let's talk about the conspiracy theory
that says Joe Biden will get reelected
with the help of Taylor Swift did you
guys see that Baltimore Sun said Taylor
Swift should be the
VP yes no yeah I should actually pull
that one up oh The Baltimore Sun she's
very very busy right now I don't think
she could actually Baltimore Sun wrote
that after the Ravens lost check us out
that's very disloyal The Baltimore Sun
forget K Harris put Taylor Swift on Joe
Biden's ticket read her commentary so
she stops coming to football games and
they said that people are excited about
the RAV in the Baltimore Sun is excited
because Taylor Swift might come to
Baltimore to watch the game did some
Googling blah blah blah she will be 35
years old in December 13th 2024 her net
worth is 1.1 billion she can afford to
take uh take what for her would be a
volunteer job yada yada yada y okay for
sure for sure right now you've got two
big conspiracy theories that are kind of
overlapping with each other the uh
Kansas City Chiefs beat the uh Baltimore
Ravens everybody out here is pissed off
we're in Maryland so everybody out
here's Ravens fans and they're losing it
they're saying the refs were not making
they're making bad calls they weren't
calling out pass interference it's BS
they're pissed but you know that's
sports right well the conspiracy theory
is Taylor Swift and Travis Kelce it it
is a it's a scop by I'm assuming the
Democrats in the Deep State I guess so
that at the Super Bowl she can endorse
the Democratic party and tell to go vote
is is is that that's that that's
basically what the SC plan is I guess
that's her Arc she she's been slowly
getting into politics over the last few
years yeah I mean she endorsed Biden in
2020 but the thing is she's not very
helpful right now she's literally on the
intern she's about to start the
international leg of her tour it's not
like she's it's very unlikely she's just
going to drop in if Biden's campaign
stops if Biden's even there himself I
think this is a s up I think that's a
fact in what way do you think that that
two PR people got together and said Hey
Taylor Swift would you like to do a
celebrity relationship like we've done
with insert every other celebrity it'll
make us a bunch of money and she was
like sounds good so it it's a s up in
the sense I'm being somewhat factious
but I love when the left's going to take
that one out of context and my point is
that this happens all the time celebrity
publicists say who can we put together
the NFL was like that'd be great we'd
love to have Taylor at the games how
much will this cost Taylor's people are
like look you show up to a bunch of
games you hang out with your friends you
do this fake relationship everybody
makes hundreds of millions of dollars
the ratings are going to Skyrocket for
the NFL and there's a lot of money be
made with the Super Bowl you know how
much ads cost we bring in those ratings
there's going to be a ton of money they
offer her a bunch of money I think it's
more likely that she's just doing stupid
publicist
nonsense that being said I think the
more plausible conspiracy theory is that
ratings for the Super Bowl have been in
Decline uh a US cultural uh homogeneity
has has gone I mean we used to have like
yeah Super Bowl everybody watched
everybody watched Big Bang Theory now
nobody does and so there's this play
like we're going to create this romance
love story Travis and Taylor and he's
going to propose to her or something big
at the Super Bowl and if that's the case
all the people claiming that the game
was rigged because the the Ravens seem
to have thrown the match or that the
refs weren't calling it properly it's
because the Chiefs are going to win
Taylor Swift and they're going to have
their moviees romance and and Travis uh
uh proposes to her or something and what
makes the most sense is it's it's
publicity it's marketing that's so is
Kelsey part of the S up or is he being
sced
so in the literal in the literal sense
of what I think is going on uh Travis
and Taylor are engaged in a publicity
stunt that's it look look look I just
want to stress this sorry man 10 of
these happen per year publicists will be
like Jennifer Aniston and insert
celebrity do you guys want to be seen
together at the club and we'll get a
bunch of press generated about you so I
look at this and I see it as no
different what they started dating what
at the beginning of the season is that
it July in July I don't know when
football season starts I'll be honest
with isn't isn't that the right before
the beginning of the season I don't know
training camp I feel weird cuz I'm
typically the guy who thinks most things
are scops but this one so it's weird
that we've had this role reversal but
like to me this just just seems like one
of those organic things of her being a
victim of propaganda becoming this like
political activist over the last few
years we've seen her crying in that in
that documentary she made about abortion
I she barely is she barely is until and
the only like real uh legislative issue
I've seen her get behind is anti
stalking laws which seems very
applicable to her life uh but sorry I
don't want to cut you off no I just
think like and I also know these
publicity stts do happen I also know
there's there's history of things like
the World Series being rigged so these
things are all plausible we say these
things people might think we sound crazy
there's there's history there's evidence
of these things happening with her I
just feel like she's such a victim of
the ideology that she's a part of and
and the News she the news diet I I I
completely disagree how many instances
can you name of Taylor Swift doing
political activism I think of that docum
I think of in private one time she was
talking with her parents about how she
wanted to help Biden the only time I can
think of it actively other than the time
she like held up those Biden 2020
cookies was when she campaigned for uh
was it Mar not Marsh black that's what
I'm talking in Tennessee and one of the
issues she got specifically behind was
anti-stalking laws like support of Mara
I I'm gon to look it up because I don't
want to say the wrong thing I doubt it
was an an supportive martial blackborne
I thought it was about abortion I'll
tell you not abortion it was anti-
stalking for sure what really grinds my
gear on this whole thing about everybody
claiming she's a Democrat scop is that
she posted on Instagram that the Soros
family robbed her yes and I'm like my
friends my brothers when Taylor Swift
says Soros bad you go Taylor is so right
and you go to all of her fans and you
like can you believe what the sorosis
did to Taylor yes they're bad and then
and then what you do is when they're
like yeah that is bad you go now look at
this article about George S and
everything else he does and they're
going to be like wow those are bad
people primed an entire generation to be
aware of and angry with the Soros and
for some reason there are conservatives
held bent on pushing the narrative that
despite the fact she publicly complained
she was robbed by them she's secretly
working for them no if she's a s up my
think my thought is that she's actually
unintentionally a s up for the country's
pro-natalist movement I love all those
articles that are like if they get
engaged this summer there will be a baby
boom because all of these girls will
look at their boyfriends and say but
where's my ring we need to have children
immediately like when Taylor Swift
declares that it is time cuz I mean
what's interesting about her tour right
now is it's the AOS tour right she's
giving a little bit of music from
everything she's put out so she is sort
of cap stoning her career she's got this
attractive new boy friend she could push
off the coast have some kids Inspire
women around her I don't think it's a
Democrat thing I think it's a
pronatalist I'm actually going to
combine what you both are saying and I'm
actually going to say screw what I was
saying earlier about her not being a
scop and actually she's positioning
herself to become the new Soros that's
after that Aros is over she becomes what
if the real the real war that's
happening is that China through apps
like Tik Tok and social media have been
manipulating digital platforms to make
young people sterilize themselves get
abortions and push all this stuff and
the real sop is as you described getting
Taylor Swift to have this movi esque
romance relationship at the Super Bowl
then announc she's having babies to get
all the young girls to try and be wives
and have babies and reignite America
look I'm in love with you guys I've had
this you someone go into the archives of
Pop Culture crisis I gave this Theory a
long time ago because when she broke up
with her other boyfriend of six years
which by the way that's too long to date
uh I'm sorry it just is she would write
these lyrics about how like she wants to
be married she wants to have a child
whatever else and then they broke up and
so I honestly think she's 34 years old
she is ready to settle down she's at the
capson of her career she is going to
lead our country's uh Rising birth rates
and I think we should all thank her for
that but let's going back to this big
thing where everyone's claiming she's
going to endorse Democrats they're
saying it frustrates me but this a lot
of conservatives are like she's secretly
working for Soros she's going to endorse
Joe Biden out the Democrats win let me
show you some numbers to assuage your
fears a Taylor Swift Instagram post
helped drive a surge in voter
registration from September 22nd 2023 I
saw a post by that guy what's Brian
Tyler Cohen or whatever his name is I
don't know they love playing these these
weird games he said vote voter.org saw
100 50,000 people visit the site and a
115% increase in 18-year-old voters the
wild thing about it is first the 115,000
people 150,000 people showing up on that
day is relative to nothing he didn't say
it was an increase or a decrease it's
quite literally just their standard
traffic check this out from NPR they say
when Taylor Swift speaks her fans listen
no they don't that's actually fake news
on Tuesday Morning the singer posted a
short message on Instagram encouraging
her 272 million followers to register to
vote afterward the website she directed
her fans to the nonpartisan nonprofit
vote.org recorded more than 35,000
registrations according to the
organization they say the 35,000 and you
notice how there's this like muck in the
in the middle this this pattern you
scroll down the
35,2 52 new registrations on National
voter registration day were the most
since 2020 the organization said and a
23% jump over last year do you know what
that means the most we can attribute to
Taylor Swift's post is
8,17 voters she's got 272 million
followers they're not all American but
I'd have to estimate more than half are
well maybe even not about 272 million
yeah she's probably got 100 million
followers I think half is an easy thing
to half yeah because she's an American
personality but with massive worldwide
appeal even 100 million half of those
are probably already registered to vote
so let's say 50 million unregistered
let's let's you know what I'm sorry
let's be as Fair as possible let's say
only 50 million of our followers are
American half are unregistered 25
million she got 8,000 people to register
I'm I'm sorry she could not get people
to sign up for her website for free and
everyone's like she's going to endorse
the Democrats yo I ain't worried about
it at all when when when uh Brian Tyler
or whatever his name is tweeted this I
checked the numbers and the fascinating
thing is when it said a 115% increase in
18-year-old voters that number was like
17 it was like a remarkably small number
increase and it's like it was a 72%
increase from 2019 and 115 from last
year and I'm like wait a minute that
means even less people registered the
year before how many people has Scott
presler personally registered like in
comparison I think who is more effective
Taylor no question substantially more
than Taylor swi doubt it easily I went
out it I uh much like uh modern feminism
being demeaning to women this idea that
Taylor could change a woman's vote is
weird because I also wonder how many
conservative women are fans of Taylor
and they could separate you know her
politics with her art I see a lot on
Twitter do that you know what what what
a weird idea right can you correlate the
apparent disinterest in her fans and
their politics to her fans taste in
music guarante l i I guarantee
Facebook's algorithm knows your
political pers
if you don't say you're it'll it'll it
all out so for Taylor Swift I mean how
many on Instagram they know exactly
who's voting and we know this is true
because we had Dr Robert Epstein on and
he said that Facebook sent Democrats
when 100% of Democrats got a a reminder
to vote on Election Day only what was it
59% of Republicans got the same message
people need to watch that episode on
it's on the culture War it's a crazy
crazy episode like how do you cheat an
election it's really easy Facebook says
all Democrats get reminded to vote half
are Republicans that's it they're
allowed to do it it's free speech yeah
what did they do wrong because they
didn't promise to do anything right like
they don't owe it you to remind equally
spoke Free Speech until the FBI comes
and sits in your office Mr Zuckerberg
and tells you what you can and cannot
publish on your platform let's be real
they're likely going to his office and
saying make sure to remind all the
Democrats yeah yeah what do you think
Taylor swi what do you think her effect
on our nation's political landscape is
well I been in the music business long
enough to understand her connection I
get I actually get it although I'm not a
fan I can look at her I get it I can
you're not a closeted Taylor no no not
not not in the least and but I can
listen songs no that's what I'm going to
say if you listen to the song and you
can see and understand if you if you
know anything about music at all you
understand why that song connects but
that doesn't mean that I like that kind
of music it's not what I listen to i'
I've had to sing it before myself I I
like videos of that I like Taylor
Swift's music proba uh not all of it
like some of the songs actually I'm just
like that's not a good song but uh she's
got her hits that I really do like
however I must say if you uh asked me to
choose a
song and uh like put me up between
Taylor Swift and like tulle I'm gonna
pick tulle every single time I I will
put sober on repeat 100 times before I
play a single Taylor Swift song that
said if Shake It Off comes on or trouble
like I know the words yeah a little bit
like and they're fun songs I wouldn't
choose listen to it but I like it you
know what I mean it's like you can like
some kind of food you don't order it if
you get the choice you get the choice
you're going to go for like a you know I
don't know like a ribey medium medium
rare but if someone gave you a filet
you'd be that's good too no I've had my
own corporate dance band for 23 years we
have to play shake it up right it's
mandated by law it is Corporate dance
band is a good name for a band actually
should be thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net